I'll tell you why the election yes
please all right so no one likes Donald
Trump right
Hillary Clinton was supposed to win
Hillary Clinton didn't win and everyone
was shocked you can watch it was a
part-time job send you links the Indian
guy can't remember his name leader if
you uh he's the head of Google and a
bunch of other people Jack Dorsey who's
head of Twitter all these social media
companies ones we're talking about their
leaders are on camera saying we can't
believe we let this happen we think this
is our fault because we let Donald Trump
share his information on social media we
have a bigger responsibility to people
to prevent this kind of news getting out
there and start talking about censoring
after Trump wins the first election they
start talking about how it's our fault
that we let this evil man into put into
the power because we let people think
for themselves and it was supposed to be
Hillary even though Hillary's caused
more Wars and killed more people than
anyone ever she destroyed living I Trump
I like Trump sorry I don't see I don't
see how he changed the world into the
good I like Trump yeah I it doesn't
matter if I like Trump I don't think you
should read elections [ __ ] Trump you
shouldn't ring elections you should let
people decide who leads how do you know
they are real okay so we're gonna get
there so the social media companies
already admit they had influence right
so Hillary is supposed to win Hillary
didn't win so then the Democratic party
and the Democratic party are closely
linked with all the people who run the
world we'll talk about Epstein's Island
and [ __ ] all the kids and all that
second in a second all Democrats right
so the Democratic party or the are
linked to the people where's the black
where's the black book where's the book
where's the list they have the list
they've got the list for those of you
don't know Epstein would he would keep a
list he had cameras everywhere in his
house and he'd keep a list of everyone
that came and and what they did so that
way he had influence all over all these
large political figures so he was like a
puppet master at the top of it because
he had proof over all these other people
it's it's a crazy thing there's some
websites that you know join my Discord
if you want the truth I mean he and his
girlfriend Epstein is dead
Maxwell she was kind of uh his his Madam
who lured these young girls in and did
whatever to get them to become sex
slaves she's in jail now for it and she
knows who all these famous customers
were she knows who they all are why why
hasn't it become publicized imagine how
deep it goes that they haven't
publicized it I can't like it's got to
come out pretty convenient are there are
there we should do a little research
like are there any groups out there uh
suing for that information isn't it
crazy that the media immediately went to
it was suicide too when he died wow like
that's that was the story that was put
out I mean that was that was like the
press release that was put out yeah yeah
no the the guards were taking a six hour
nap the cameras went out and um you know
the when they did the the in his Anatomy
it didn't make any sense yeah there was
a lot of Suspicion around that test a
lot suspicion that's a funny word for
that for that so they watched Hillary
Clinton a lifelong politician and the
woman uh the first woman in Canada and
the wife of Bill Clinton they watched
her lose to Trump so then they get Joe
Biden who's senile who's suffering from
Parkinson's who can't talk I had a time
friend and she's a friend she's been
married
we owe these truth to be self-evident
all men and women created by the goal
you know this you know the thing
and they run him against Trump and they
know he's going to get we already talked
about this today when he was yesterday
so this this video that we're watching
is is old and so it's kind of funny
because a lot of the things that Tate is
talking about have actually come to
light as being true but today or
yesterday excuse me Biden was speaking
and he was like talking about this
legislation and he was like going in the
audience where's Jackie is Jackie here
oh maybe she's not here and Jackie is
this uh congresswoman who was killed in
a terrible car accident at two months
ago and you know they put out a
statement about how tragic how sad they
were that she died and how you know
important she was and all that he didn't
even know and today he's like we're
looking for her yesterday looking for
her in a crowd while he's speaking where
where is she at Jackie representative
Jackie are you here where's Jackie she's
dead yeah for two months she's still
dead thanks for the Instagram story
landscope know that right he doesn't
stand a chance against Trump Trump's
smooth right yeah so the Democratic
party who just had a literal meltdown
YouTube Google the most powerful people
in the world had a meltdown genuinely
crying tears worrying that Trump's now
president and our life is over Donald J
Trump is now president of the United
States
[Applause]
[Applause]
come on
then they get a senile old man to run
him against Trump and it didn't cross
their mind for half a second to rig it
they didn't think Hmm he's going to lose
this he needs a bit of an advantage of
course they did so how do they do it
here's how they rigged the election they
used Corona as an excuse saying that you
can't vote in person you can't if you
want if you want to take the huge risk
the huge risk but if you want to vote by
mail you can vote by mail don't worry
we're going to send mail ballots out and
everyone can vote by mail then as the
election results are being counted let
me just stipulate this never in the
history of an election in America has
the results taken more than 24 hours to
count never in history here we are seven
days later they're not finished so
that's the first [ __ ] thing that
doesn't make sense right in fact here's
why because Trump is winning in a
landslide of course Joe Biden you can't
put a sentence together the dude has
been vice president for 47 years and did
nothing for anybody who the [ __ ] likes
Joe Biden nobody right so Trump's
winning a landslide they stop counting
overnight for random reasons I was
watching the election in real time me
and Tristan argued about this Tristan
goes Trump's going to kill us and now
they're going to rig it and even my
brother goes you can't rig the U.S
election I said watch this we're
watching it for the first time in
history ladies and gentlemen for the
first time in history before they
stopped counting oh uh a Walter pipe has
burst in Georgia oh uh a Court ruling in
Nevada says that because of the way the
polls were done we need 24 hours for a
bunch of garbage legislation right I'm
telling you why burst pipes [ __ ] and
then overnight they open up all the mail
in ballots oh [ __ ] and Joe Biden's ahead
now what's funny is they opened up the
mail-in value
and they're all 100 for Joe Biden 300
000 votes not one for Trump not one for
the independent candidates all every
single one for Joe Biden okay I'll send
you I'll show you the graph yes I've
shown you a graph which shows the graph
shows because they're stupid enough that
the graph actually shows the votes right
and you can see that at 4 am on a random
Wednesday Biden goes straight up this is
[ __ ] rigging this is election rigging
if you had to flip a coin and get heads
300 000 times in a row what's the odds
of that happening considering that every
other state it was 58 56 57 a hundred
percent
around the world
and then or even questions
so then Trump goes this is rigging
Wisconsin Right correct Trump's winning
and bang this happens at 4 a.m overnight
that's convenient boom straight up I
know I have the new battery coming sees
this you know what he does he sends
Republican he says Michigan the same
thing same thing
as possible I don't know I'm just I'm
not saying he's right okay but he's
saying I just want to know he's
compelling it's possible because the
Democrats are rigging the election using
mail in voting and they're using mail-in
voting to because because they're
scaring people with Corona it's all
about control when you control people
you can rig things
the Communist dictator Stalin said it
doesn't matter who votes no matter who
counts and he's completely right you
control everyone and you count the votes
and oh I won so they rigged this whole
thing right so when Trump saw this he
sent Republican inspectors to the
polling stations and they were locked
out which is against federal law really
it's against federal law you can lift
this up he said the thing and they were
locked out and they and the Democrats
counting because this happened in
Democrat uh Democratic states right they
covered the windows with paper this is
all on video what I noticed when I was
brought in to be a poll Watcher
um I was never brought in actually I
never got past
the first identification stage they kept
saying that mine as well as five or six
other Republicans uh their names hadn't
been entered into the system and after
the first time it happened the second
time it happened I was
had no second thoughts about it being a
problem more that somebody failed to
finger us into the computer system but
after a while what I witnessed and I I
said to Mr Giuliani before you know in a
morbid curiosity staring at I felt
Insidious fraud going on I felt that we
were kept away from doing our civil Duty
that was everybody on both parties
should be upset about this is horrible
we're being restricted we're being
restricted the thing is too that there
was stuff that went on on the right that
wasn't like I I saw I don't even
remember it but I'm pretty sure that
there was stuff that the right did that
was um some shady [ __ ] too and that
doesn't surprise me like they're both
[ __ ] the right isn't Angels you know
what I mean but I do want to look do
more research into that because I am a
lot more educated
nature of the Philadelphia Pennsylvania
oh yeah this Andrew Tate podcast is shot
a man
what we were meant to do and Trump's
like well we're going to take you to
court and recount is all [ __ ] 15
000 dead people voted in this election
this is common knowledge I will send you
the link now what people have been doing
is going on death registers getting
people's Social Security numbers and
then putting it into the mail-in ballot
system to see if your vote was counted
15 000 dead people have voted
dead people people were born in 1890
it's all a rig the whole thing is fixed
to make sure Joe Biden wins by a mail-in
ballots and mail-in ballots comes from
coronavirus it's all fake you can see
here so now Trump's going to go to the
ex to the Supreme Court the Supreme
Court has all the evidence they need of
election rigging and then Trump's going
to still be president and there's going
to be a civil war it's going to go off
because all the Trump haters think
they've won if you're wrong man all the
Trump haters think they've won now also
I'll give you the most solid proof that
cannot be denied have you heard of
Benford shut down at every level Google
benford's law if you're watching this
Google I can't help but just to wonder
if they just don't want the you know
that was Civil War the unrest that would
come from from that and the absolute
distrust that it would that it would it
would be irrevo irreversible damage
amount of distrust in the system another
thing if he could ever prove that yeah I
know if that actually went through and
they revoked the election it would be
like the fall it would be like the fall
of the USA essentially how would you
trust anything anymore if the there was
proof that the election was rigged and
they went back and made Trump president
yeah I don't know I don't know how they
would how we like at this point we just
have to leave it alone because as a
nation we could not recover from from
that and then another thing they did too
was after Biden won then when like the
the raid at the capital and stuff
happened and Trump tried to send
National Guard help there and you know
like give support they shut him down he
actually and then before it had happen
that's I know that's what I'm saying
yeah and then they blamed it on him now
when there's a politician that voted to
overturn the election or do more
research into it they just go oh he oh
he voted to overturn the election
despite having the the capital being
raided what kind of person would do this
that is a legitimate commercial that's
going out that they're saying that oh
it's crazy that you voted to have an
investigation no yeah he voted to
overturn the election even after the
capital rate right which what is this
worse than 911 which is yeah CNN and
MSNBC going off how the capital rate was
worse than 911. the capital doors were
basically open they let them in
everything was conveniently just like
gone they stole a couple laptops with
nothing on it that [ __ ] that was meant
to happen they wanted them to go in and
read the capital it's all on [ __ ]
purpose
outside of the whole like the whole
thing was shitty and I I wish it never
happened but whatever but my favorite
part of it was uh just my from an
entertainment Factor was how uh AOC I
just go off on her because she just
sucks so much she was uh she was in in
her office two blocks away towering and
she came out afterwards and said she was
traumatized in therapy because she was
so about Trump being terrified during
the quote-unquote Insurrection we had
guard sneakers at this in the video we
had they brought in dogs and and like
therapy sessions for kids to go to when
Trump won I went to Boston no you're not
listening during the what they're called
what they call the Insurrection which if
you look up the definition of the word
insurrection they would all [ __ ] their
pants if they ever saw a real
Insurrection because it wasn't okay so
she said she was in her office two walks
away and she said she was so terrified
that she had she was crying for days and
had to go to therapy okay this is a
congresswoman who I'm supposed to feel
confident it can make decisions about
life and death and War and health and
money and two blocks away you had a half
an hour when you were a little shaken up
or wondering and that was your reaction
to sit in a ball and cry yeah and then
carry on about it for weeks after like
this victim mentality and everybody's
like oh my God the poor thing like no
you're supposed to be strong you're
supposed to be a leader
oh my God
[Music]
[Music]